[Música]
un paisaje inmaculado y salvaje de 170
kilómetros cuadrados
los altiplanos deber corso constituyen
la reserva natural terrestre más grande
de francia metropolitana
un territorio sin carreteras ni
viviendas permanentes
una tierra hostil donde los pocos
visitantes deben arreglárselas con los
elementos
bryce para la guardia forestal es uno de
sus protectores
una de las especificidades de la reserva
de los altiplanos de ver corts es que no
hay hábitat humano permanente entonces
el invierno nadie vive ahí durante el
verano están los pastores pero casi no
hay infraestructuras humanas
para llegar a la reserva tuvo que
caminar una hora entonces saborea su
pausa para almorzar en un marco
extraordinario
es relativamente accesible es un lugar
conservado típico del medio montañoso y
mini montaña sí es una suerte poder
estar aquí cotidianamente a pesar de las
apariencias muchos animales pueblan los
alrededores una de las misiones de price
palette es justamente estudiarlos para
protegerlos mejor
aquí hay un rastro de liebre durante el
invierno la presencia de animales se
traduce mucho en rastros
así es como los vemos bright palet
también tiene otra función informar a
los senderistas de paso hola cómo está
muy bien las condiciones son buenas si
hay buen clima
los rastros del lobo en la nieve y los
rastros de un perro de un gran perro se
diferencian bien
lo típico con respecto al perro es que
hay cambios de dirección
y uno tiene la sensación de seguir el
rastro de un solo logo en un momento
dado usted se dice son dos y vuelve a un
solo rastro es eso lo que nos hace decir
que se trata de lobos
[Música]
el nuevo no es la única especie salvaje
que puebla la reserva natural de ver
cosas aquí conviven especies y
meridionales montañosas o continentales
como en ningún otro lado poblaciones
poco comunes y discretas price palette
descubrió justamente una familia de
rapaces trata de ubicar un nido
escondido en la roca
en efecto hay un ave en el nido y ahora
hay que ver su comportamiento
no eligieron un lugar muy plano entonces
son jóvenes
no se puede excluir que el huevo no
caiga que el joven no sea parte tampoco
lo que nos interesa es que el vuelo de
los jóvenes sea un éxito tendrá que
permanecer durante horas en este sitio
para tratar de saber más antes de
regresar al valle
en el barco los hombres se acomodan en
la naturaleza lejos de la civilización
para pasar una vertiente a otra hay que
recorrer caminos empinados como la combi
la vall separada de la montaña
suspendida a 500 metros abismo
paso obligado para el cartero lo hará en
casa quien casi pierde la vida en
1998 había nieve pero era nieve grasosa
mala caía al barranco el vehículo se
volcó y al cabo de tres o cuatro tumbos
quedó contra el marco vamos a detenernos
en otro mirador tanto en verano como en
invierno el recorrido de loren cassez lo
conduce hasta aquí cada día a pesar del
peligro es un hombre feliz
es una vista extraordinaria
antes estaba en la región de parís
prestaba servicios a la torre de la de
fonz con 50 pisos
cuando veo por ejemplo a veces la
neblina en el valle y que estoy arriba
que el cielo es azul me tengo para tomar
una foto así lo haya hecho decenas y
decenas de veces
una bocanada de aire puro y loren retoma
los 90 kilómetros que recorre cada día
pequeñas aldeas con casas aisladas
tal como aquí en futuro
a 1500 metros de altura
loren conoce todos los habitantes
nos llama nos comenta las noticias
locales que no sabemos un nacimiento un
fallecimiento que será mencionado en el
periódico mañana
y el enlace en nuestras pequeñas
regiones lo hemos perdido
[Música]
pero hay una cosa que nos ha perdido la
tradición de la nuez aún vigente en los
altiplanos de haber corso cosechas en
otoño es en invierno que son exprimidas
con piedra de amolar para transformarlas
en aceite como un gusto inimitable tal
como aquí en el molino de león
aquí pongo el fruto que fue aplastado y
lo caliento el hecho de calentar el
fruto permite fluidificar el aceite con
la temperatura para luego extraerlo con
prensado el segundo objetivo es poder
despejar los aromas
obtener el buen gusto del aceite de nuez
y este aceite es muy suave tiene un
pequeño gusto de avellana o pan con
mantequilla
yo también
por fuera cuatro meses al año la nieve
cubre toda la región
una imposición natural que hace que este
pequeño pedazo de paraíso sea de difícil
acceso lo cual es un placer para los
principales habitantes